Jesse Tyler Ferguson praises his Modern
Family co-star Ariel winter Ariel is
really a wonderful young girl last year
Ariel winter revealed that she underwent
breast reduction surgery and ever since
she's been flaunting her bikini bod all
over Instagram I think it's awesome that
people find me interesting on Instagram
et was with the 18 year olds Modern
Family co-star Jesse Tyler Ferguson on
Thursday in New York at a special
screening of his new film ice age
collision course the actor revealed why
he's so proud of Ariel and her body
positive message I'm proud of all the
kids on our show they've gonna have to
be you know amazing adults when we met
these actors and actresses they were 12
13 years old and now they're driving
themselves to work and they're
graduating from high school and going
off to college it's really you know I'm
proud of all of them in Ariel is really
a wonderful young girl and I yeah she's
a great future in front of her I think
she's studying to be a lawyer smarty
jesse also shared this update about his
other co-star Sofia Vergara husband Joe
Manganiello who suffered some recent
medical issues I've been so busy I'd
Sophina have only texted a little bit so
uh from what I understand he's doing
he's doing well